In this section, we will explore the MetaHuman DNA calibration repository.
Throughout this course, I will be referencing the 2023 Unreal Fest DNA calibration deep dive presentation
delivered by part of the three-lateral team.
This is one of the greatest resources and explanations of the DNA calibration library,
and I have linked the presentation in the resources section of this course.
Now, let's review what the DNA calibration repository is.
The DNA calibration repository is a C++ library that gives users access to the contents of the MetaHuman DNA file.
It has a Python wrapper making it accessible to use with DCCs outside of Unreal Engine such as Autodesk Maya.
The tools enable users to further customize the MetaHuman rig as well as to modify DNA files and use read and write operations on DNA files to change the rig.
The tools include the DNA Calib C++ library which is used to manipulate DNA files and DNA viewer which is used to visualize DNA in Autodesk Maya.
In simple terms, DNA viewer allows users to look at the DNA file and do things such as choose what LODs you want to assemble and what properties you want in them.
DNA calibration allows you to take these things and through commands you can manipulate the rig, the joints, the meshes, and blend shapes for specific pipeline needs.
Some of the things users can achieve include setting the number of LODs, renaming or removing joints or meshes, setting skin weights, vertex positions, or blend shape target deltas,
and once finished making modifications, users can export the DNA and bundle it with the FBX so that when the modified DNA and FBX files are brought back into Unreal Engine, the MetaHuman face will behave correctly.
DNA calibration is the recommended toolset for calibrating MetaHuman DNA when finalizing customizations to the neutral pose for Engine versions 5.5 and earlier.
Now let's take a look at the MetaHuman DNA repository.
The MetaHuman DNA repository is available on GitHub and can be accessed using the URL listed on this slide.
A good place to start is by going to the readme file which includes information on how to set up the library and what can be achieved.
Inside of the examples folder which we will be taking a closer look at later on, users will find examples of code that perform functions such as removing joints, viewing the rig with textures, and exporting the DNA head LODs as FBX.
Users can combine different functions from here and create their own scripts.
The Unreal Fest zip contains the assets and scripts from the 2023 Unreal Fest DNA calibration deep dive presentation, and this is a great example of how users can combine simple and advanced functions and bundle them into a single script.
Now that we have a better understanding of the DNA calibration repository and some of the things that can be achieved, in the next section we will touch upon different approaches and expectations for achieving likeness using various MetaHuman framework tools.